what animation should be the next
live-action movie The Incredibles
because imagine Elastigirl in that CGI
Big Hero 6 because I had the biggest
crush on Tadashi Hamada Cars 3
specifically wait The Emperor's New
Groove I feel like it just it's written
itself and that's easy to recreate it's
real people yzma Cronk I am saying that
they should do Madagascar A Bug's Life
they can have it like you know Homeward
Bound where the animals it's real
animals they use real bugs I don't fully
understand the meaning of live action
especially when it's not just a bunch of
humans I think it would be silly as hell
to see live-action Monsters Inc however
a real answer that I'm just now thinking
about how about a Spirited Away Stitch
gasps everywhere ready